welcome everybody to the h3 podcast love
every Friday except today which is
Wednesday
history productions today's episode is
sponsored by me Andy's movement
naturebox and Dollar Shave Club thank
you to them next week we have a philip
defranco on at our regular scheduled at
time and we're gonna put a threat up as
we usually do give questions for us
asking today's guest is a close dear
friend of mine he's uh I gotta I really
got to thank this guy for helping us so
much when we were coming up dude did it
yourself
genuinely one of the greatest boons we
had coming on thanks dude I think it
made such a difference for us you hired
ela you brought us out to New York when
we were like nobodies sounds weird as
hell but you know I know everyone
alright no yeah and you've just you've
always been an incredibly generous and
gracious friend to us thanks Dan I
genuinely love this guy I know I it's
been too long now that I am officially
you know guest number eight six hundred
thousand and five just kidding no dude
you guys did it yourselves I saw can I
just say now that was too much I don't
know if I can accept no it's not it's
not enough it's not enough and I want to
say for the record you are one of our
most requested guests right I've been
looking to this looking for this for a
long time meets have you've been hard to
get a hold okay it's not just my phone
I'm just kidding all right I'm your New
York guy you have [ __ ] panic attacks
every time you come in you start every
conversation was like hey do you have do
you hate LA oh that's been a while Bob
do this city
look I don't trust the city unless I can
see its air okay unless you can see its
air yeah no but but is it wait well New
York's not exactly the cleanest place in
the world are you telling me trash bags
on the side of the street with with
maggots it's logging into into the
rivers of the streets is not clean also
I just like saying as a clam by the way
yes
it's also dirty you can't see the air
here though malaria no but I was gonna
say as a qualifier to that I was there
for it's funny because when I look back
on a lot of this like especially like
the vapenation video which is just bring
you up beyond any because I remember the
the day that you went to film it you
texted me and you said hey do you have
any ideas for like funny weed gags and
you were just like going out there and
you guys were hustling every day I say
whatever they want I was there every day
they were just hustling like you know
some new ideas some new things it's
amazing to watch this meteoric rise
thanks you guys did appear so you are a
huge influence on me like even before
like even before we were friends you
were huge influence on me
Thanks and just being able to spend that
year with you in New York like in close
proximity and be able to be inspired by
you was a huge to be around you like
because we played off each other it was
mutual yeah it was it was honestly like
in retrospect it was it was such a great
year a wholesome year for us like it was
only and I think most of our fans think
back on that year is like our golden
years yeah well I you know there's
always like golden years when you're
doing YouTube and yeah I know what you
mean it was for me too in a sense
especially just being it was it was a
fun year but I just it's so funny to see
how big that that vapenation meme has
become and I just remember you guys just
going and doing it it is great now I'm
so happy seems like you're doing all
right for yourself we got some walls we
got some curds trying you know we're
trying to go hustling yeah yeah anyway
it's great dad thank you love you too
both so how is it to be back in LA do
you hate it as much as I grew up here so
you know that's what pisses me off about
la is the traffic oh so we're just
making sure it looks and sound okay but
you can keep going yeah I can you bring
the mic closer yeah thanks sorry I'm new
to this now this would these miners as
if you basically have to [ __ ] suck
Canyon all right it's suck that mic I
didn't know this was part of the
equation here is this close enough can
you all hear me they're saying there's
too much contrast too much contrast what
do these guys [ __ ] stanley kubrick's
Cass goddamn it to professional
operation on transit you got a purple
couch
I thought us coming into a real gig dude
here's it here's a complaint I'll accept
I can't see too much conscious get it
too much get what you mean like in the
in the levels of color anyway whatever
okay um why do you hate Ellie so much I
don't hate LA you Harris used to know I
grew up here you know I it's just it's
it's hot and it's smoggy and there's a
lot of traffic and I think that got to
me over the years so la is a very really
depends where you live yeah it's like
anywhere where do you work yeah yes the
traffic is enough to drive anyone mad
yeah it does if Gandhi lives in Santa
Monica and he works in [ __ ] Burbank
he's gonna drop that nuke yeah I used to
have a job actually in downtown LA
working for an electrical components
manufacturing company I worked the
backend of the servers for the their
Joomla system they used to the backend
you're a programmer no it's it's I
basically just ran their website very
good at it anyways and I had to drive an
hour and 10 minutes both ways like so
two hours 20 minutes total in traffic I
think they just broke me a little bit I
don't know oh yeah yeah I was enough to
break any but I don't really it's this
Amin it's like no but it is like
Vietnamese like its water torture where
you're like it's enough to break any man
yeah I think honestly I just really what
I like I like full four seasons and you
can't get that out here that's very true
yeah but I've invite or the street where
we lived there's like a couple of orange
leaves like on the street and I'm like
oh my god it's full no right like take
my [ __ ] actually sometimes yeah
sometimes I go back to my hometown and I
see there's a little bit of a fall yeah
it's not a bit it's a muted fall you see
a couple get your pumpkin spice yeah
what do you like about New York cuz you
are a very genuine New York guy people
think about you're a New Yorker New York
has an energy unlike anywhere else and I
think part of it comes from the fact
that it's a diseased [ __ ] right
probably you think you have
really the the allure of New York is
part of the it's it's um how hard it is
to make it there if you can make it
there you can make it anywhere there's
an allure to the city but I think the
more you live there you start to be like
well actually I think it's just coated
in in what they tell themselves to make
it through the day yeah I think part of
it is just you know putting yourself
through the struggle of making it in New
York it's but you know I'm older now and
I I've moved out to Queens I know for
any of you Manhattanites out there
unthinkable getting to that point when I
try to move out it's fine big yes big
for you we lived in Manhattan yeah and I
felt like I only went to Queens a couple
times my whole [ __ ] year there I know
I got barely left Manhattan and a couple
times that went there I was like this is
great yeah it's all right yeah
Queens is nice where did you go like a
story uh yes yeah I don't even look down
I look around I look like deep Queens we
did a guy I have family there [ __ ] yeah
well I'm like in a house now it's
detached and has no one oh my god
grown-up boy now are you still living in
town houses but I think like I wanted to
blast honestly whatever you've really
changed I know I told you I'm not the
same old Johnny yards now and driveway
take care you yard yeah well Alyssa
found things I'll go and change some
tomatoes we have a basil plant it's
really nice we have free basil no
seriously this trips me out when you go
to play yeah in church we had about
gardening it's so it's like a self
explains it's obviously stupid but like
I don't have to go buy basil I have free
baby yeah we bought it from Jose and we
used all the basil from it and then we
said let we need to nourish this child
badly we've destroyed him and when he
said nourish him we planted it in a
little open patch this basil plant we
bought from Trader Joe's
you okay so you meant Trader Joe's you
just called it Jones yeah this is LA New
York yeah we do but it's not Joe's there
we call it then I'm like a mess I'm fine
now yeah what they call Trader Joe's in
New York is I'd rather [ __ ] it and kill
myself this stand 50 minutes to buy a
five pack of tomatoes you know it's so
funny because we always we always were
like talking you know having that we was
that nice not that long I got super fun
rows like the line it's longer than any
Trader Joe's just want a chocolate bar I
wanted to have you been to Joe's in LA
well yeah I mean I grew up here so I see
you about goes here Oh Joe is great you
go to Joe's the parking lots full you
look man I can't I have to wait like two
minutes to find a parking space this is
so full you go inside there's like two
people max at the register like that's
full capacity here you're the Trader
Joe's in that broth side we used to shop
I swear to [ __ ] god you guys would
think that there was a famine and this
was the last tomatoes on earth you
shelves are empty
he's not joking there's a there's a
sneaking lion-o sometimes out of the
bill do you just to get in there's a new
building there's a guy bro holds a sign
that says this is the end of the line
just so you know it's because you
wouldn't believe how long but I have to
say there is one thing I will give it
credit for is that cashier system runs
really quick right it's fast
I got it I got it it's bad I got it bad
well at first I was like there's no way
I'm ever going in there and eventually
we caved and I'm like you know it's at
least half the line it looks like at
that speed I agree
but there's still something humiliating
about saying there were a bunch of
[ __ ] it's like man yeah and then you
remember like the rent you're paying in
your apartment you're like what am
paying a lot to stay like this long what
do I do I understand the complaints but
I will say for that time that you lived
there the Upper West Side is a magical
place bro I Love New York's great
walking outside
we were like literally two minutes from
Central
yeah you know man it was underneath our
apartment yeah it was close it's cool is
that what called the bucks no clucks
Ellie's changed you man
did I just grab a couple I grabbed the
bugs gonna head up jealous again it
makes you settle in for the night
it's fun to live that bohemian life for
a while but then you yeah I had to park
my car in a garage next to my house and
it costs like I'm not gonna say you say
because I know and I'm fat and I ran
nobody is gonna respect me after they
know how much it takes to park my car it
was eight hundred dollars a month to
park I thought it was fun I had no
choice I had no choice unless I was to
move that thing across the street every
like Wednesday or whatever it is sweeper
yeah I New York City all you need to
know is that it costs $800 per month the
park you're [ __ ] paid that parking
wasn't even that I don't even want to
use it because it's so far to walk - no
that was my old parking spot no no I'm
doing on my street it was actually next
to my townhouse that's and that's why I
just said screw it I'm gonna pay a
little bit more because it's [ __ ]
you know and I'll tell you I'll tell you
the funniest thing about this place is
you pay that much right and when I
called them to get my car every time
they'd be like man like can you give me
like two hours notice
I'm like just that's all you do didn't
they crash your car once I got I leased
a beautiful baby green Mini Cooper that
was my first car I ever leased I never
liked it and I was so happy with it it
was brand-new and I did in that in that
garage the one you're talking about the
far one and I got a call and I got it's
a bit of a problem here and I'm like
what do you wanna do some what do you
mean a problem I come there and they
have somehow totaled my car in a parking
lot it was the whole side of the car was
completely couldn't open the door
smash and I had to had to go through
like a big battle with them and they
never ended up paying for it I just had
I remembered that they were an answer
your phone no they wouldn't answer my
phone cause I call them hundreds of
times and so I just said screw it I just
want my car back so I paid Geico the
deductible thanks guy go well sorta
that is some of the [ __ ] you dealt with
that year would have made me lose my
mind that was close man like um on top
of paying some spineless [ __ ] some
[ __ ] [ __ ] $800 a month like who
even has the balls to ask that it's just
the free market goes I know I'm kidding
I'm kidding but nobody you paying
someone so much money just for the
simple act of saying here you goes your
car and I know I can crash it and don't
take responsibility I I you know I can
get it i I've come to Zen not coming
peace with that
I'm sorry bringing it up it's like in
the moment I remember going there be
like you're gonna pay for this car it's
just gotta buy things are just not going
to and it's gonna stay broken until I
fix it what did they do what are you
gonna do and they know what are you
gonna pay a lawyer I know that [ __ ]
you're gonna end up at least five
thousand dollars just to write him a
letter we were there do you know do you
know what ended up happening they
resented me after a while like every
time I come to they give me like this
this side stare and I'm like you broke
my car wouldn't fix it why you mad at me
so I moved that's that's one of the main
reasons I moved it to be here an Eiffel
episode straight up New York to the
second garages credit they didn't wreck
my car in a parking yeah somehow oh that
oh you're gone you gave him the chance
they didn't ruin it
oh yeah I was actually that one for a
while but now I'm out in Queens and I
have a driveway that's a great
development I'm really happy about that
for you so let me ask you about the D
monetization [ __ ] going on YouTube is
like yeah the talk of the town yeah I
don't want to like beat a dead horse I
think everyone know I'm scary about but
I'm curious if it's affected you funny
thing I've seen you know like I like
even like you know like PewDiePie I've
seen had some D monetization is using I
think have you guy said oh yo yeah yeah
I've never been hit by one I'm like the
only seriously green oh I've never been
hit by one but I said is pretty
incredible and I and I've been trying to
speak out in as best I can retweeting
like you guys well it's hard to care one
like no really I really do care I think
it's terrible thing they've done but
like I I've been trying
I think it's all that close to you both
sorry yeah I'm sorry this thing's like
it's got all kinds of moving projects
like that cradle it the thing is I just
want you to be comfortable yeah I'm
sorry I just I'm not you feel free to
like get weird with it like you can
bring it with you like Danny same time
but dance for your enjoyment okay so um
so basically what I'm yeah no no I cared
a lot about it
the the only thing is I mean I didn't I
just wanna make a video about because
everybody else was you guys handled it
well enough I don't need my opinion on
it so but you know I was trying to get
the word out there but no just it it
didn't hit me I thought it was really
interesting I thought it was ridiculous
what what they were doing with that
because the thing the thing about
YouTube that that really I know it like
you said speeding a dead horse that
really pisses me off is they don't tell
us what to avoid right right they don't
give us any sort of warning or anything
and like that now they have this manual
review system but I remember there were
a couple times where I had explicit and
this is just a whole different issue but
like I had explicit permission from like
a movie company to review their movie I
would and they D monetize my video
because of copyright or something and
then I go do the review thing and I'd be
like here's the proof and they'd be like
denied sorry and I'm like are you
[ __ ] serious did you ever contact the
company uh you know I just was like
watering the bridge I don't have time
for this bro it happens yeah yeah that's
I mean I'm happy that it doesn't affect
you that is kind of an encouraging and a
way to know that people are getting hit
cause it seems like everyone's just
getting bombed on but maybe it's great
as I mostly just do Lane I just like do
like what's the last video I did flex
tape turd I'm surprised to hear ducking
was family-friendly I mean your your
content generally is very very clean
yeah I guess it's clean I like to keep
it fun and I don't I guess I don't talk
about like current events and stuff
we've seen like people with very clean
content who still get the monetize it's
just god bless yeah yeah in the Boogie I
saw some apple boogie if you're watching
buddy what's up uh love you hey Shh yeah
you don't want yeah oh the really big
dig I'm kidding that's usually just how
you start thank you
I love it but no it's just I love you
and I love you anyways the the I saw
that like some of the original like do
you member like the old Boogie videos
like the Eric the Frances the Frances
stay of course yeah
and that was like getting hit and I was
like yes it's classic you do this what
built YouTube modified it's like
revising histories with yeah yeah and
then there was this recent add gate with
I don't know if you saw it though did
you see that weird I don't know I've no
such it huh Elsa gate was it Elsa it was
that weird like child bro I've been
talking about that for so [ __ ] long
maybe a year since spider-man and Elsa
now it's like it's been there I'm kind
of I have mixed feelings on that because
I feel like I gave them I made 3 videos
about that a year ago and I feel like as
a result they were just like [ __ ] this
guy talking [ __ ] about YouTube do you
think I don't kind of our channel got
shown there's no question about it like
a year ago
when we were in LA for a moment our
channel got [ __ ] I do remember you
guys were like upset about it it's
better it's better now yeah they change
they change some of their policies that
are way more fair now and to their
credit but now they're acting like oh my
god this huge problem about [ __ ]
pedophiles on YouTube who could have
possibly known that but it was even
weirder than what was talking about it
either no cuz I feel like the other one
was just like kids videos aimed or like
videos aimed at kids that were weird
sexual sexual but that's different this
was like this was a whole nother level
this was like possible kids but it's all
connected there was very there was very
sexual videos that we were watching back
then of like you know [ __ ] women in
thongs and like the cartoon I remember
we watched of spider-man tackling Elsa
off a toilet and like raping I remember
cuz I see show me them I remember give
me your house one time you're like Jon
would you look at this one where'd you
find that even maybe what that really is
though that creeped me out those videos
I made me
honestly is I feel like nobody there's a
lot of great people at YouTube and over
the times we've got to know a lot more
people from Google and YouTube and
they're all having soup yes they're
great people they care and they work
hard and I think part of the mistake
that YouTube makes by being this
faceless corporation and being so tight
and so like inside baseball they never
tell you what to do
ya ever tell you what's going on they
create this really deep chasm divide
like us first then yeah and I know that
the people are good people there and
they care and they're doing their best
but I feel like somebody very high up
I'm not gonna say the specific person
names I don't wanna start a witch-hunt
but I feel like the person who's in
charge of YouTube very very high up
needs to fall on their sword Oh whoo I
don't know what the heck that's what
they needed somebody to take a fall like
the company and all I said what do you
mean like yeah you know symbolically for
some state they need a [ __ ] change
something okay yeah yeah that's the
thing I never really don't be taking
responsibility or accountability there
I'd I never did see it as personal from
them I just see it like a corporation
thing faceless thing like you said and
but that's not good either you know what
if it's from their perspective I can see
they have all these different factions
all these different types of channels
and they have to keep them all happy and
their advertisers I guess they just
start seeing it like one big amorphous
blob and they're just chipping away at
it you know I completely agree to
juggling act it's a juggling error for
them and and I and I'm not envious of
the position is so important it's so so
hard to manage but I think they've lost
sight yeah of what is the whole point of
this [ __ ] yeah I think I think you could
you're right about that
but you know the thing is too about
YouTube is you know for all the [ __ ] we
give the site it's pretty cool Oh
hundred percent
you just make you can make whatever you
want and you get paid for it it's
awesome I'll be the first one to admit
right now that I give them more [ __ ]
then they deserve and less credit than
they deserve it's always how it is
though right when you want to get
something fixed when I guess I'm fixed
yeah you want to talk about the good
things it's easier to complain and get
fun fuse and get people riled up than to
actually be like congratulate them on
doing real stuff hey this is just like a
personal thing I'm saying like I've when
it comes to the issues you guys have
talked about a lot of the issues that
they've had over the years I've kind of
been like y'all right
I know I'm sorry I have [ __ ] sorry to
interrupt you know acid reflux it's like
the coffee is brutal man anyway go ahead
say sorry like I've always you know I've
been sort of iffy on like which things I
think like I thought some things were
like I don't really care about this I
can see where they come from to this but
this recent D monetization stuff so
stupid I I think somebody is it fixed no
it's getting worse it's getting worse
because the ELSA gay [ __ ] you were just
talking about has made it way worse and
now more advertisers are pulling out
they're making more restrictions they
just banned a bunch of channels and
videos and everyone's just getting
[ __ ] murdered here's the reason I
think it's specifically bad because it
just discourages people from making
things at all because of that one of the
biggest things that youtubers rely on is
when I put in the effort and I put that
video out I'm gonna be able to pay my
rent right we don't know anymore I mean
I put in and everybody knows this and
it's a meme I take a long time in
between my uploads because I put a lot
of effort in them if I uploaded one and
it just didn't get monetized yeah that's
my that's it it's really not I mean
that's very real and especially in
people like yours case because there's a
lot of youtubers and the platform favors
it who just they crank them out yeah and
that's what they're good at and that's
what they do I'm not criticizing that
way of doing it but it's easier for them
to stay afloat yeah and I think what
they're doing well you touched on is
discouraging content like yours yeah
unintentional unintentionally of course
and also like some you know like
obviously there are some tags that are
more volatile than others and they're
just kind of like making a there I think
the best word is sanitizing they're like
making it so some people are like well I
could talk about this important thing
but it's gonna get D monetize so screw
it right and we could have had some some
awesome thing that now this person this
swath of people is just discouraged to
do in general I mean there's a debate is
like is D monetizing the same as
censorship I mean clearly it's not the
same thing but if there's there's like
discouragements that therefore it's not
exactly censorship but it's like you
know such a strong deterrent you're
repressing a certain I'll tell you one
thing I always hear this arguments these
super libertarian arguments about like
well you know you can make your own
YouTube if you don't like YouTube but
Twitter YouTube Facebook
these are the public square of the
modern day right
they should be unfortunate I know I like
this their utilities uh yeah they need
to be regulated I kind of agreed that
they are utilities because if you like
you can say that you could just go talk
somewhere else but where and how are you
gonna like that's that's where all the
discourse happens I don't know it's
complicated you're right it's where
we're all trying to navigate this
unknown territory it never never at any
point of time has a private company
controlled so much discourse it's just
bizarre tech knock twenty technocracy
Socratic yes yeah that's the thing about
all these people is they kind of have
the the final say on what's acceptable
what's not and and you could like just
go on some other website and talk but
the thing is with the speed of
information that travels today nobody
goes to those I disagree it's not it's
not a it's not a feasible thing like oh
just go make your on youtube it's like
that's not [ __ ] happening in the next
20 years go make your own raw highways
dude basically like that is a perfect
analogy yeah you know yeah it's a wreck
Sam you know that you're never gonna get
like a perfect free market or a perfect
social thing you know you need a little
bit of okay yeah that's right I think
you got to walk the middle path yeah
these companies are so entrenched it's
like we just have to accept I mean I
don't know I mean for the most part
they've been relatively responsible but
I think it's just so annoying when for
example a video can just be not
recommended and you wouldn't know that
yes and then as a creator you'll get
less views and you think the video
wasn't good they don't need you to or
the stats or the algorithm and it's just
if there was more information things
would have just been bad you know
different but the way it is now is so so
discouraging for creators well that's
and and that's true by the way of
Twitter Facebook and Instagram they
don't tell you but they manipulate yeah
they do definite the way that your your
interaction with the world performs they
definitely do and they and they know
that it reflects on how you feel like
Facebook has openly said that they
manipulate people
their moods and stuff creepy to me and
what that yeah it's creepy
I [ __ ] hate they're the worst the
best meme bro
Mark Zuckerberg ur cuz what I call
needing a sandwich with my human
relatives oh that sweatshirt wearing
grimy [ __ ] weirdo dude what does that
guy doing his basements man I know you
seen that series of things where he's
like out in the world being like I am
human too no oh it's so funny
oh I summon VR with someone and it was
like the most Awkward day was like okay
we're in Africa now pull that video Mark
Zuckerberg sampling his VR is so far we
got oh yeah we can watch videos anyway
we're gonna take a break okay we will be
right back thank you guys for watching
having a lot of fun a short short break
we will be back soon with your boy
jontron thank you to me undies for
sponsoring this episode of a stream
podcast listen have you ever got
underwear for a gift and you're like
what did I do to deserve this
you know does this person hate me well
guess what you can now give underwear as
a gift this Christmas and the person's
gonna know you love them because it's
such a terrific pair of underwear maybe
the problem isn't the person it's the
underwear itself let me tell you about
me undies
the only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift you look can you please
I'll be showing while your explicit name
of that price is right lady the famous
one dan what's her name Vanna White yeah
your van you're gonna be my Vanna White
here so much so look at this it's soft
it's luxurious
I mean oh my god I smell my own baba
ghanoush because I have warranties I
smell it but it's not the underwears
fault that's really my own fault dude I
love wearing me undies it is unlike any
other underwear on the market it's soft
its flexible it's got four big Fupa boy
like me you need those soft flexible
waist bands because I chafe and even if
you're thin it's even better because you
know you don't have to deal with all
this tension it's three times soft in
the cotton it's natural sustainably
sourced fiber
capiche me Andes made underwear the
perfect gift that everyone's gonna love
it's a goddamn holiday miracle I love
that listen they wrote in for me to say
it's a goddamn holiday miracle you owe
it to them to buy a pair I love their
collars and pythons its donuts and
mellow colorful oh yeah it's like oh and
oh what's that a little purple enlight
hmm people guys see that you're like
your date's gonna see that and be like
oh my god
well [ __ ] extra taste there inside
purple am i what else is in those
underwear right hopefully not purple but
tasteful as well this holiday season
guys get 20% off the softest underwear
and socks you will ever wear free
shipping 100% satisfaction guaranteed
this will make a great gift for anyone
go to me undies comm slash h3 that's me
undies dot-com slash h3 thank you me
undies for supporting our show next
we've got movement and the empty these
guys make the best freakin watches at
the best frickin prices you've heard me
talk about it you may have other heard
other people talk about and maybe you
got one yourself and you love it well
now it's time to finish your holiday
shopping and get one for someone that
you love and they're gonna love you when
they get this amazing watch these guys
founded this company on the belief that
style shouldn't break the bank their
goal is to change the way consumers
think about fashion by offering
high-quality minimalist products at a
revolutionary price these guys have sold
a million watches in customers in over
160 countries around the world
they've solidified themselves as the
world's fastest growing watch company
the most legit the most reputable ELA
show it off wearing yours but it still
looks great matches your outfit I mean
I'm I'm awed it's a great-looking watch
man you throw that on with any outfit
and all the sudden it's like boom boom
three ratings up on the oh I'd like to
[ __ ] you
I'll say your five all the sudden you're
an 8/8 a really good rating say you're a
- like you're hideous and okay you're a
- all the sudden you're a five so
somebody's be like they're gonna see
that watch you'd be like mmm I could
[ __ ] that guy you know I'm saying like
you know like this this can do a lot of
movement for you move movement it's in
the name guys and that's what they're
talking about
was that planned no it's just inspired
by how great their watches listen it
starts at just 95 bucks if you go to a
department store you're looking at four
to five hundred dollars of a watch of
equal value okay at such great prices
it's gonna make a wonderful holiday gift
as a classic design with quality
constructs
I want you to head on over what get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t-dot-com / h3
it's a clean design is gonna make a
great fashion statement guys step it up
go to MV m t.com slash h3 for your 15%
off join the movement today thank you so
much sponsoring us let's get back in to
your boy johnny Trani ye welcome back to
a street podcast here with Jan Tran hmm
well if you want to support my endeavors
I'll tell you I got a new merch store
and actually there's me there's new
stuff coming I'm chillin this stupid X
thing that I always be plugging you
gonna represent calm / jontron I think
that's the link but it's on represent /
aunt actually that should take you there
I'm sorry I never did like merch before
really but i I've just started have fun
with it and there's a new one coming up
I think everyone's gonna like it really
will yeah it's coming out probably next
month so oh oh so we have a whole
Lincoln in the chat to your store other
linking in the chat great no cool
awesome thanks guys there's also a
callin number if you guys have any
questions for us or John while we're
here there should be a number on the
screen call in her a support Ian he'll
be taking their calls and screening it
to the best of his ability
make sure to be gentle and sweet with
him he's a sweet guy he does not deserve
the abuse he's about to get that being
said we've got this video of Marc sucker
Zuckerberg look at board your board Mark
Zuckerberg er there it is Mark
Zuckerberg tried doing everyday normal
stuff the internet trolled hard
what are you milking a cow like get real
Mark Zuckerberg doing your average
everyday American things what is he
doing like what are you running for
office like why would you even care it
is inspecting Factory I am yeah Mark
Zuckerberg inspect Factory oh wow you
everyday Americans sure are doing what
was the context of this you know some
people feel he is like running up to you
know to know or someone oh no no no no
so they think I don't I mean I'm not
disagreeing I don't want proofs in the
pudding maybe none of us wanted nobody
fun and nobody reads a cow milk unless
they're trying to get some madam I know
right
nobody has ever voluntarily fed a cow
belief of the past
I am Zuckerberg drink of this beef milk
I have a grab from the sustenance teats
soon you shall be burgers it's a meme
but he's not like you here and one time
he tweeted that he and it was like a
typo son really yeah you like typos that
he wasn't actually human Morgan yeah I
wonder I have to wonder if the
singularity has already happened and if
eight Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk art
agents of our robot downfall what if
there's what if the the singularities
inside Mark Zuckerberg is mine and it is
just an AI learning about us that's what
this is bro like it's not that crazy is
it yeah it's a little crazy you know
what every freak like very little freaks
me out these days even like the whole
nuclear [ __ ] going on with North Korea
but I say when Elon Musk was like guys
we need to regulate AI it's gonna kill
us I was like scary you are must knows
we talking about guys hear me tell ya
know that's good
here's what Mark had to say about these
pictures it's my first time in Michigan
and my first stop was at the why are you
touring like you're he's running
I'll just stop by good state to give my
support to the people I went to Detroit
nobody goes to Detroit people are out of
Detroit I play a very small part in this
step and the assembling of a new fort
come on stop [ __ ] fellating yourself
yeah yeah but the most interesting part
was sitting down with some of the people
who do this every day it isn't a weird
it's very strange that he's doing this
because you know that Mark Zuckerberg EO
he's always talking about how he feels
like he can know what he wants to do and
I don't mean it's a conspiracy theory
way he's literally said like we want to
socially engineer people using Facebook
algorithms and it's like dude weird man
I think the problem is he he I gin and I
don't mean this like derogatory but I
think he has autism
he probably and I don't think he
understands that saying I want to
socially engineer people or like not
look like full-blown autism but like
Asperger's where he doesn't really
understand why what he's doing is so
creepy yeah it doesn't seem to really
understand that it's creepy it's kind of
funny though it's it's why it's just
it's a combination of like and so far
removed from normal life yeah I think it
could be even without Asbury burgers
just yeah just you start something and
then you get so involved in it that you
lose reality imagine if you were at the
top of a pyramid of an entire of a world
encompassing social media platform and
by u ticking a box
you changed the course of like discourse
or history could get it that's like too
much power is for you too much power
he'd to imagine writing this but the
most interesting part was sitting down
with some of the people who do this
every day
it's like bro did you not know that I
even stood within one foot of the human
I'm there I dare not step closer bro
this [ __ ] is weird man yeah it's been my
it's been one of my guilty pleasures the
Mark Zuckerberg but wait you guys find
me the one of the VR because the I don't
know if this is it here let me let me
keep going down here's a video yeah this
has got to be good oh this is 20 minutes
long
franki footages people baggage so I've
been going around to different states
for my personal challenge for the year
to see how different communities are
working across the country sing how
people are living about their work and
their hopes and challenges yes that's
good he will literally destroy all of us
hi I'm just going to sweep oh no it's
the weird part
I guess help some guy out hey you know
what's weird about this the way that
he's like publicizing it I think that's
that's the just a personal mission it's
one of those things I guess when you're
when you're somebody like him you're
like well why not document it but still
just it wouldn't be it would be but look
at this if it wasn't so weird though how
can you not understand that this is
funny yeah I know right plastic like I'm
I am one of you I know it is because I
guess like when you grow up in the city
I can say I've grown up in in Los
Angeles and you know live in New York
and we don't feed cattle milk bottles
normally dictator tucks in a roast beef
sandwich what do you eat what actually
do you eat I'm ready to go show like
what a regular guy Thank You fellow
humans for sustenance
this sandwich is woefully insufficient
yet makes my taste sensors live again I
love about this or a picture of any
other human being go to stock photo type
man eating sandwich there's a thousands
of them it's green like he's doing
something good he's pleased with you
know it's my favorite robot man meme
what am I gonna show you just together I
know probably everyone watching is sick
of seeing Elon Musk memes but you may
not have seen it and I'm [ __ ] love
itself
back off haters haters will say they're
tired of this meme alright Elon this is
a called a zipline and humans they enjoy
this oh let me start that all right you
on this is called a zipline and humans
they enjoy this they enjoy it very much
Elon then I shall enjoy it as well
[Laughter]
always dress in the Larry David Steve
Jobs attire right I don't know what it
is it's like I have risen above fashion
absolutely not transcend like the Bill
Gates the bill the bill gates doctor
it's the Bill Gates doctor it's some
sort of Buddha thing he said under a he
said under a tree of money for seven
days I heard a joke about I don't
remember who said it but they're like
you know why Bill Gates will always be
rich and people like you always report
look at the way he [ __ ] dresses bulk
the guy saving on every corner man guys
find that video of him doing VR I need
to I need to watch that oh yeah you like
with families too bastard that was a
great little how dare heroes should
communication ever video talk to humans
now [ __ ] that guy it's here higher up oh
wait let me find it oh here it is thank
you guys really
we got it the Armand a man women over
here I got you bye so here he's doing
well oh he's doing a vr Facebook a trial
for Facebook's VR space by visiting
Puerto Rico after the hurricane
devastated hurt well you might want to
visit somewhere else
well cut the [ __ ] is just bizarre man
here he's gonna be all broken up
go quickly teleport there okay look at
the devastation we are in a 360 video in
in Puerto Rico I danced oh the humanity
and can you turn it up for us damn you
can kind of get a sense of what like
they're like they're like strolling
through a war zone with literally like
the hot the AI transcends to to look at
our model how he's like holding on to
the camera like physically like oh the
memes write themselves recently it's
flooded it's a it's flooded yeah wow I
would not want to be here yeah well if I
didn't have a magical were to teleport
back to my penthouse Wow
well wasn't that unpleasant I think I
got a sandwich and some tater cuts
[Laughter]
I think Zach Zach posted it to Twitter
lucky to find just the link no
description I was like what is this I
click it I'm like oh man good I might be
I think it was that I know which makes
it even more
Rachel can you take those glasses off
and get a little [ __ ] serious I know
this is someone's neighborhood you can't
yes you can't you can't look concerned
wearing Gucci shades I mean this is
where we're looking right and you wanna
you want to jump in Facebook VR and go
look at some national tragedies let's go
to their places in Uganda where they're
so famous you won't believe there's
basically children dying of starvation
right before your eyes and it's in fact
one of our top attractions in our VR and
our Facebook VR studio this was like
remember in Sim City where you could you
could have them the the natural
disasters come through is the modern
version of that right want to see some
natural disasters up close how the [ __ ]
do I know that he's not the one who sent
it game he could have one flick on that
algorithm it's a butterfly effect
somewhere off the coast of Costa Rica
area that Facebook is is very focused on
to make it said all my people in the
community could tell their friends and
loved ones that they were safe we
activated beeping over community later
eyes their eyes food shelter and usually
in the community could provide that if
they had that we once again he's
probably trying to do something nice
yeah he just comes off every time it's
like how can you not know the optics of
this I love it others in it there's more
I would watch this all day wow there's
like 4,000 of these this is very
underground meme I think we should make
a video about this yeah maybe that's
what this is right now
that'll be uh then you want highlights I
hope you guys enjoy you know there's
gonna be a highlight for sure and
include this part okay now cut alright
where were we
without the hood alright let's let's
let's switch out here okay let's get
this out of the way yeah it's the
elephant in the room yeah I see I was
wondering what the [ __ ] that was oh yeah
been awful just so intrusive yeah you
had an infamous debate yes with some
debate that got you into a lot of hot
water it happened how long ago was that
now I don't I don't keep track I don't
know like nine months or something
anyway like there was there was a lot of
backlash and a lot of people upset about
about what you said in it and I guess my
question is was I I don't want to get
too deep into it because this is a fun
light-hearted time I'm not I don't want
to debate anything with you I don't want
this to be anything negative at all so
if you're uncomfortable with things like
you don't have to comment at all like I
know you've moved past it and it was a
really hard time for you yeah I'm sure
I'm sure people want to know about this
so I just get it out of the way cuz I
haven't talked about it since then for a
good reason I don't really want to get
into this it's a minefield of sorts I'm
not gonna go back and nitpick everything
I said and say and qualified or anything
all I'm gonna say is that yeah at that
moment I was you know going into
something that I needed a lot more time
to prep for I just went in guns blazing
cuz I you know you get a little arrogant
sometimes I guess you think like I'm
gonna take this kind of task but you
know like obviously I understand like
why people had the reaction that they
did it's not as if you know I look back
at some of that and I'm like wow [ __ ]
did I say that like this is done no
matter what right or wrong it's a
[ __ ] bad luck there you know I I'm
aware of that
but um you know yeah it's it's pretty
simple like I'm not really gonna get
into it but oh yeah I guess the main
question on everyone's mind is all
here's the erase this is he a Nazi
simple answer and this what everyone
wants I mean you know no I treat every
single person with the same respect they
afford me so you know I felt bad about
the incident in in the sense but like I
also just feel bad that we can't
talk about these things without
witch-hunting each other right because
you know that that's basically my full
statement okay mm-hmm
I mean did you say do you feel like you
said some things that you regret
yeah it could phrase a lot of that
better the whole thing was that like
just to put it in perspective for you
when I the second I went into that
stream it was an instant bump bump bump
moment right I was not I was thinking to
myself can I just would it be weird if I
just was like oh sorry mics breaking I
don't like reliving it now did you have
a lot of self-aware moments during that
before the whole time you just said oh
my god should not be I was wondering
that I was like personal I was like if
they're I'm not the person to fight this
battle right well let me just say for
the record like that I I disagree with a
lot of the stuff you said you know but I
but I still think like it's a you if you
genuinely feel a certain way or some
people genuine feel a certain way the
correct way to deal with it is not to
like prevent them from saying it yeah
we've been seeing on it we should be
able to [ __ ] talk about like even if
I strongly disagree and even if I'm like
dude that's that's [ __ ] up but I think
that we should still be able to talk
about it I mean I don't know it's tricky
like it's tricky but is it an impossible
task for someone as a family if you say
something they really disagree with is
it an impossible task for them be like I
really like I'm trying to get them on I
really disagree with that I hate what he
said but I still love him as a person
and as an entertainer I guess that's a
timeless question
yeah well it's that's been the fit
that's been through the ages you know
right but at the same time I really just
think that I don't I just don't want I
really don't want to get into this I
would like to move on as quickly as
possible because I just really don't
wanna get into this but I mean it's it's
I don't think it's a stretch to say the
current social climates insane yeah and
we're sure and I mean the only way we'll
ever get past it is just talking about
stuff
I don't want I am a community that's
really I'm not trying to get back into
this but people always ask me this I
just put it to bed now ya know I treat
my answer will be I just treat people
with the same respect they give me at
the end right
don't want to hurt anyone yeah it's just
and that's me don't want to get into it
past that okay fair enough for you yeah
okay okay I kind of want to ask you tell
me if you don't want to talk about but I
wanted to ask you stuff that I find
interesting not necessarily about like
how about your actual pinions about
stuff but like more about like the
fallout from it what about it like I
mean how did like sponsors and fans how
are you feeling at the time cuz I'm sure
it's not a great time no it wasn't
wonderful but I mean now you get past it
I mean like you you grow you learn you
know you can't be perfect all the time I
know some some things are more larger
than other things you know but like no I
just took it in stride really I was like
I I like making people laugh I like
doing comedy people still want me to do
comedy so I just I clearly yeah I've
just continue down that path and I don't
really feel like dredging it up because
pointless
I'm not gonna get anything else out of
me from it yeah just like there's
nothing I have nothing to say I'm just
more interested in like the the journey
you had I was like you did you went
through it it was something that sucked
obviously and a lot of times past and
like you feel like you've learned a lot
from it or you're in a better place now
learned the yeah I've definitely learned
like one of the biggest things I've
learned is just you know how to have
restraint or like rephrase an argument
well right so that comes off a certain
way right you know like it's hard to
miss it sometimes you just screw up one
year when you have all the eyes on you
and also sometimes and I'm not really
making excuses this is just like
sometimes when when there's so many eyes
on you you just crack a little bro
totally I can play that's a something
I'm trying to work on with myself it's
like you go from being a normal guy they
can say anything you want yeah to being
someone who millions of people are
watching yeah and you you need to learn
to be thoughtful I didn't realize the
impact like the far-reaching nature of
yeah you don't because you're just like
YouTube we live a bit more of a indie
life for youtubers so yeah I think that
in general like just to be more
thoughtful I don't know
because people respond better to calm
collected absolutely that's pretty much
you know that's like the main takeaway
from me it's better all around yeah for
everybody sometimes but it's hard and I
did and you were an emotional state yeah
I was an emotional state and I'll tell
you what it's not defending by the way I
just want to say for the record I'm not
defending what you said I just state
again for the record I disagree with a
lot of the [ __ ] you said but that's fine
like yeah I like I'm not gonna be like
I'm still talking about it that's part
of the problem is that people were like
I can't believe that you're still
friends with John and I'm like why he's
the same person like I love him he's a
good friend of mine like we can talk
about this stuff amongst each other and
try to find a common ground right like
it's way better to have a disk have a
conversation and try to understand each
other otherwise you just end up with the
segregated groups people who hate each
other yeah like you really expect me to
just be like [ __ ] off you said something
that I disagree with and I can't talk to
you anymore like that yes how sick is
that yeah I agree I mean yeah that's why
I didn't want to get into this too much
because I don't want just I don't want
anyone to take anything I say out of
context I don't want them to say are you
making excuses for this what do you
think of this you know it's just this is
I'm just giving you like general I
forget what my train of thought here but
I do like it's something that I'm just
focused on comedy now that's fair I
understand it's a wait sir by the way
you're doing very good thank you is
there lots of videos we're really good
thank you so much like was this like
yeah and and I and I noticed you I mean
you you disappeared for a while off
YouTube how long was it between derth
you know that that was mostly just me
reorganizing but it was for a while six
months I've done it before I've done
eight months yeah yeah I guess I mean
you're you're notorious for just
disappearance how I am well I'd like
this happening I never talked about
what's going on there well usually the
thing is I I've never been wonderful at
consistency and considering that I do
most of this stuff independently
considering I do most of it myself
I have to like get it already and you
know I prepare the budgets and
everything so sometimes
or like for instance you'll notice in
between the in that break like we built
a new set and all that stuff and you're
like rig the lights it takes a while
sometimes and I'm not I'm not like I
can't make me just quickly cuz usually I
edit them and it's very like minutely it
takes me a really long time I have an
editor he's great you know I have a team
yeah I'm just very involved I guess I
just I always like when I put something
out for me to feel like it's a hundred
percent how I want it to be and it's a
weakness as much as it is a strength
yeah yeah but that's just how I am and
how I've always been and it works for me
so yeah I wish I you know I'm trying my
best right now especially I'm trying to
get over my fear of just trusting my
instincts because sometimes I'm like I
second-guess myself like I don't like
this or there's something I call upload
phobia yeah sort of that I feel like
when we especially if we take a break
for some reason it gets really harder to
get back to it the longer you go from
posting those wire gets to come back
yeah that's very that's very true and
that's why and I'll tell you what yeah
because the expectation is higher from
you you come back that's why like you
better have the [ __ ] best view ever
he said six months to work on it when it
comes to youtube I feel like it's you
just have to keep a ball rolling YouTube
is and it could be really it can wreak
havoc on your mental stay sometimes
sometimes lutely sometimes really I'm
just like I don't know I'm out of ideas
you know I don't know what to do
fair enough that's fair I think what I
love about your channel and that I
always have is that there's a myth among
youtubers that if you walk away from
your channel it will die yeah we all
feel that we gets us a riot and you
single-handedly demystified that I feel
like like genuine if there's anyone to
prove its me it's good encouraging it's
nice to know that you can actually just
step away for a healthy amount of time
and come back and and your fans are
still there to enjoy your videos yeah I
know I love my fans seriously though the
I it's we I know I never really speak
candidly on this subject so I'm not used
to it but no I really appreciate the
fact that people come back and watch the
videos I mean I put my heart and soul
into them but I am planning in the next
year to really break away I've already
done a couple videos and I usually come
from what I normally do but I'm gonna do
some stuff that's really like
it won't even be the same format but you
know that's the thing is sometimes you
have to take risks like that or element
comes still yeah I don't know well I
would say I've observed since you've
come back from your most recent break is
that the nude like there's definitely a
new direction there's a new feel and I
mean he'll love it
yeah thanks I was so much fun and it
feels fresh you know your junk lashes
you really feel that way yeah absolutely
yeah I mean and beyond that like they're
doing great yeah it seems like bananas
became alike oh man I get messages of
flex tape all the time now do you know
what's funny I was literally just like
you need you know what so I got no I was
just like in my in a local pub in
Manhattan and I was just like drinking a
beer like and I and I saw the the
commercial on like a TV screen up like
by the bar and I was like he saw the
boat in half that man to sell tape and
and then I just was like this is so
funny gotta do video on it and I really
didn't expect people to I I expect the
most people to either say like I've
already seen this commercial or it's
just a stupid video but I don't know I
have some reason it for some reason it
just becomes such a big big mean I don't
even Jerry Seinfeld I don't know if you
saw my video but Jerry saw people were
tweeting me that on Jimmy Kimmel he was
asked what his favorite TV show was he
said the flex seal commercials on Jerry
Seinfeld's desk somehow yeah Jerry
Seinfeld saw my video you're watching
Jerry Seinfeld which I know you are if
Jerry Seinfeld sons secretary second
cousin
brother-in-law is watching this video
and I mean get in contact with your boy
Jerry get it out there quick they were
sending out feelers anyway I was really
happy to see you come back and like like
off I don't want to say Phoenix it was a
bit Phoenix like you came back legs
strong and everyone so hate to see you I
feel like it was an even on your suck
like there was like such turmoil on your
subreddit during that happen but I don't
what like came together and was super
supportive and was like just behind you
as it can
like that's how you want to be well I
want to be I just want and so I thought
it was great I was super happy to see it
all awesome I appreciate it
and I tell you what I'm having a blast
doing it and in 2018 I hope I can bring
some some some more joy and laughter to
the world that I just want to put more
positivity out there and you know what
it's like that's really it
I know it's stupid yeah it sounds corny
but it's really like when you can really
realize that I mean it's really I'll
tell you one thing cuz I tell you so you
know I'm not bullshitting cuz I am
really bad at lying by the way I'm
really [ __ ] about it like I'll tell
you one thing don't work at the moment
you know everything has gotten so
topical and I saw like some comedy
specials on Netflix and it's like
uncomfortable it's like we just some
people just need to laugh you know yeah
just to laugh yeah
and I just I like providing that kind of
gonna be honest there's some there's
some people to do that some don't like
Jimmy Fallon I don't like the guy
personally I don't find him funny but he
refuses to talk about Trump doesn't
watch oh he does I think that he
specifically said he doesn't get into
that because he wants it to be
yeah it's divisive you know like all the
other enlightening shows he does a
little bit but I guess not in detail he
doesn't like go after and it's not like
personal it's not like hey Trump was in
through a paper towel it was not funny I
know you know I remember you got in
trouble for like wrestling his hair and
humanizing the man way what yeah
Jimmy Fallon got in trouble I just on
his show and just went like this to his
hair to prove it was real or something
oh that's great who wouldn't want to do
that that big trouble and you like
tearfully apologize or something why he
was like I'm so sorry IQ man dies this
monster wait he's in Dan pull up the
ruffling and the aftermath of the
ruffling but this is but I think that's
a perfect like this world has gone mad
it's a man apologize for ruffling
someone's hair it's a chrissake because
I tell you what I'll tell you is like a
boy who cried wolf thing it's like yeah
when you make that the worst thing what
if somebody really does a bad thing what
do you say about that we can't we can't
it's like overload its overload at that
point or or we just let it slide because
like meanwhile we know that everyone's
like in Hollywood's been raping
everybody and and like we're just like
uh like it's just oh man it's like just
when you think it'll settle down like
you got those
flowers today I saw that I was like can
he say he's gone forever is good fired
him 12 yeah the news hour that guy looks
like he [ __ ] tucks his kids in that
night yeah I know it's apparently
grabbing ass I don't really understand
is such a vault of volume of sex
scandals I would I'm sorry yeah I'm
really shocked I'm laughing I started by
not being shocked because every woman I
think I've seen some sort of thing but
now I'm shocked
because there's so many like what it's
never-ending that's the thing cuz there
was always this thing like believe women
and it's like no I believe there's it's
gotta be out there I know it's out there
yeah but like to this scope shock out I
feel like it makes me feel like kind of
a it makes me feel like I wasn't as
sensitive I mean I I had not reasoned
you when I was like because all every
woman has this opinion about a certain
opinion about men I don't you mean and
like it seems like every single woman in
Hollywood no matter how famous they are
has had a really awful experience with
some creepy guy alright yeah and that's
what should women with the I know it is
that yeah people yeah really powerful
famous woman are getting yeah dog so
yeah so imagine what's yeah you know I
hate pandering to these subjects but
like I really do I know what you mean I
was like damn really was that [ __ ]
bad my dad I know and I think it's
important to reflect on it I think take
any blame for it I didn't do anything
but like I don't feel I'm just it makes
me more thoughtful and like just I guess
how I mean there was no way for us to be
like to know what was happening but it
is it's definitely something to reflect
on there yeah it's an interesting
subject and that it just came out that
like Harvey Weinstein like if this guy
couldn't get any worse he was like sex
trafficking people at Cannes wait was he
really yes oh yeah we I remember what
was her Lupita Nyong'o the I think she's
like an African actress she was that
sounds about right
um I think she's from Africa the thing
is she she had a thing where she he was
basically like he tried to do that to
her and she was like no I'm not gonna
[ __ ] do that and then he who's like
okay you're blacklisted and he would
just do that dude he's a mom and then
and then later when she became
successful on her own accord um like he
was like oh [ __ ] I have to tried to like
be like sorry sir but yeah I don't know
but apparently that's just what was
happening there but like the weirdest
ones like Matt Lauer you've got Charlie
Rose you've got louis c.k that one hit
home you know really neurotic weird
fetish out of all the stuff you couldn't
do that one is so weird it's a ballsy
fetish literally yeah I I gotta say III
gotta say that one I was just like dude
you could have wrote that one into one
ear stand up I feel like it was one of
his standing yes he didn't he I don't I
hate the part the part that was so
devastating about that is that it was
like one of his jokes and the fact that
he never talked about it made me calling
the question like because he was like
hey I'm a guy that talks about anything
I want yeah I mean while he's doing this
[ __ ] that's like so insane in and it's
very weird like it's a premise of a
hilarious joke yeah that's awful
yeah I don't know like I don't wanna get
myself in trouble here but like you know
look at louis ck's upset we're talking
[ __ ] about might consider myself blessed
no no I know no I'm not talking about
him I just Matt I want to get myself in
trouble here in saying it's not it's not
that big a deal or something but it was
just like of all the scandals that one
was just like why it's so unnecessary
like why are you ruining your life yeah
to do that well I guess you used the guy
he has a [ __ ] real compulsion like
you can't you can't possibly get into
how sick his head must be to do that see
really anyway I can't imagine doing like
how bald like hey can I masturbate can I
draw hey me the most famous committee in
the world and you who was also famous
can I drop trou and jerk off and
frontier he did asking me
okay yes so that he did ask it was like
no hey can i yeah exactly
yeah exactly it was a NAT it was like
yeah I don't want let's take a break
hope you guys didn't think that was too
heavy like me we're gonna take a quick
break we'll be back we have got it's you
want plug always be plug in oh we
already [ __ ] by my dumb [ __ ]
catchphrase from 2012 Wow what does he
have anything new that's the washed-up
stay tuned shower you can take this
morning got him alright let's take a
break the claim you look very clear I
wasn't calling down a question you look
great oh my mom I wanted to tell you
yeah she texted me during the break and
she said tell John I said hi he looks
great
oh well you you are wonderful I do ever
meet my right they we did a video
there's [ __ ] yeah are simply lovely
yeah there's they're crazy they're
lunatic all right we'll take a break
guys don't leave because we have got so
much great stuff left
if you leave yeah blow it Capisce is you
guys soon thank you to nature box the
most slammin snacks in town alright now
here's the deal it's holidays you're
eating chocolates and cookies and
candies there's no fun left you're
gaining weight I'm trying to lose the
Fupa but wait enters stage naturebox
who's making delicious snacks that won't
make you die twenty years earlier than
you should
oh my god praise be nature here let me
try this this is the sriracha ketchup oh
my god forget about it the thing is like
you can taste that they made it with
class and like the look you can tell
it's not like insanely salty or sweet
it's like perfectly mmm seasoned angry
really good a little spicy too
these guys have over a hundred delicious
snacks they're all made with
high-quality simple ingredients that
means no artificial colors flavors or
sweeteners it's easy as pie just go to
naturebox calm and nature box will
deliver them right to your door new
snacks every month inspired by new food
trends professional chefs and customer
feedback if you want my recommendation
it's always gonna be the cashew sriracha
cashews unbelievable
I'm a sucker for cashews the other one I
love is the coconut cashew I devour
those and then we've got here try that
cheddar the cheddar lentils I mean let
me hit that way there's no risk guys if
you don't like a snack nature box will
replace it for free so what do you got
to lose
get some snacks that are delicious and
good for you god dang it right now
naturebox is offering h3 fans 50% off
your first order
when you go to nature box calm
wow that's nature box calm
your first order guys
naturebox.com/tyler wonderful snacks and
for supporting our show hmm oh where you
at lentil dupes tastes way too good to
be healthy next up Thank You Dollar
Shave Club one of our greatest most
loyal sponsors I love Dollar Shave Club
they make a great product everyone knows
what Dollar Shave Club is going on here
ok it shipping out dollars for a few
bucks everyone loves it I love it what
you may not know which I didn't is that
Dollar Shave Club also has products for
pretty much everything else in the
bathroom they've got body while shampoo
hair gel lip balm everything my favorite
top secret product they have one wipe
Charlies these guys are selling butt
wipes I'm a big fan of butt wipes once
you try it you will never go back and
that's my guarantee do and they have the
best ones ok soon
I heard they had other stuff than razors
I was sold listen at the store there's
too many options you can tell the
difference between any of them you got
to ask questions to the clerk's they
know the difference food razors so what
the hell you they're doing you expect
the minimum wage clerk to give you a
reputation on a razor get real make it
easy convenient for you to upgrade your
shave and your bathroom now you don't
have to step in a store and you get high
quality shaving grooming products
delivered right to your door because I
know you're lazy just like me maybe
you're not lazy like me maybe you don't
have time you're actually productive
unlike me either way you need this
just like the razors everything super
high quality left me look in fresh and
feel an amazing from premium ingredients
and sophisticated sense Dollar Shave
Club is changing the game my friends if
you like me you're sick of the nonsense
at the store now it's time to try out
Dollar Shave Club for a limited time
they're basically given their [ __ ]
shower shave starter upset I can't go
Thursday a shower they have a cat they
have a a pack called the [ __ ] shower
shave starter kit I like on the copy
they put a star on the eye like who's
that for me like for my benefit I'm
gonna say [ __ ] like you it's 30
shower shave starter kit for new members
it's only five bucks okay and you get to
try all their great products for only 5
bucks it's got the executive razor the 3
trial sized version of the most popular
product that helps you stay fresh and
clean and your first box you'll receive
their shave butter body wash and one
wipe Charlies butt wipe your ass is
enough I on a bit of an aside I
guarantee once you use a a 1 wipe
charlie you won't realize how dirty your
[ __ ] has always been there is no way
to fish sufficiently clean your [ __ ]
without a wet wipe it's just not
possible
you're just smearing it around with
paper you're not actually cleaning it
you're just smearing it around your
[ __ ] like why do you think every
we've done a study about that
it doesn't take much just white once
with a wet one you'll see you like damn
my ass is there's a ton of [ __ ] in my
ass telling you it's disturbing you need
both to get the job done so try this one
try the wet wipe Charlie one wipe
Charlies I wish mine were one way sadly
I don't think they can guarantee that
their one wipe that's up to you and what
you eat my diet charlie
maybe you're a [ __ ] shower Charlie
sometime then just a [ __ ] Lee take a
shower Charlie yeah sometimes that's the
case but probably in your case if one
white will get you that's not really
their fault you can't blame them that's
that's completely my fault
so you get the shea butter the body wash
the one wipe Charlie you get the
executive razor with the weighty handle
and cassettes
the offer is exclusively available at
Dollar Shave Club calm /h 3 that is
Dollar Shave Club dot-com slash h3 if
you want to give someone a great gift
they've got a super simple gift
membership and he gift cards they got
this great product it's gonna have you
covered face to cheek and and also from
face to butt cheeks as well there's no
better time to try the club and thank
you so much to Dollar Shave Club and to
all of our sponsors for graciously
supporting us if you are in the market
please consider supporting one of our
sponsors
thank you so much and now let's see what
a jan tran has to say welcome back to
the h3 podcast where booth in and we're
band and if you don't know what a booth
visits when you try to put drugs up your
ass at a rave party
sneaking in shot don't know what a
Buddhism and especially ela I know we've
had this conversation I chose to forget
it I want to call mounts a couple of
your new videos please I loved that
Indian guy you see the blooper at the
end where he couldn't say yeah do you
know why he sobered up and said the
well I think his boss was coming and I
we weren't supposed to relative guy what
just walked apart
that's why one of the reasons I love
about Philly New York is that you really
can get the realest [ __ ] you just walk
up through guys slip 100 and go can you
just [ __ ] say that bro I thought for
sure that he was an actor no oh really
yeah no he was just a hot dog guy and it
was cool you need to find him you need
some more I need more I know I feel bad
whatever you know whenever I use one of
those guys cuz we you know we get their
permission we're like we're doing this
video do you want to say a line you know
like we'll give you some cash you know
and but I feel bad because like I never
get to like mess it like I can't I don't
know what email hot dog man right so you
know I feel bad that like I hope they
like don't see it and go like well I
didn't know I was gonna be in this nah
he's great it was it was fun but we do
get you know permission and we a theist
they know the cameras on them yeah but
the the yeah he was just that's why I
love the realness of it that's why I
don't think it would have been as good
with an actor and then okay on the
Jazzercise how hard was it not to
comment on her camel toe oh my god the
comments about camel toe you know that
we almost made a video about that like
two weeks ago what I would have been so
mad do you understand what I was like I
have nothing to say except about the
camel toe
no way funny thing about this I made
that workout video I'm gonna a little
bit of a break the immersion here that
was supposed to be the that was supposed
to my comeback video and I didn't like
it at the time so I kind of shelved it
and then I brought it back so if you
guys oh my god would have been so bad I
almost shot that video really like we
remember we were it was almost like a
listing I'm like we got them the
confidence machine and it was that what
we got yeah it was oh yeah oh why didn't
happen hold on I want to go on record
here can I get this can we switch to me
are we on me yeah there I did notice the
camel toe wasn't about to comment on
this poor woman's camel toes like it's
not it is not the camel that you toe it
is the dance you dance by which I judge
you on that but oh my god I don't wanna
we're so weird especially the last one
with the dogs that was a lady
I love that's one of my favorites were
turned into a little JRPG cuz it did
kind of look like a JRPG battle right
and then ya do what's okay so what are
your long-term content goals these days
have they changed it because I never
loved you were working a lot of stuff
when I was in New York you get a lot of
long term yeah both so how does that
transform
well what I ended up realizing was that
it takes a lot to do the things that I
want to do so I'm sort of and the thing
is you know I have to keep the lights on
mm-hmm I love doing that like that's why
I've I've kind of changed it the format
a little bit recently just doing more
like general commentary it's not
specifically on games like it used to be
but like while I'm doing that I have
other stuff in the works like you said
and what well I I don't I guess I'll say
it here I I don't know if it'll happen
so don't like pound me for this but like
I wanted to do a like a Travel Show in
the style of karl Pilkington because I
love travel yeah and I'm a curvature
right I could go around the world and
convention everything right this stones
too big that that could be natural yeah
and it's something I've wanted to do and
it's fun because it's just I wanted to
sort of work with the you know like I
feel like my strongest assets like my
personality so I was like what look at
Brett best showcase then I thought that
would be a good idea is that something
you're currently working on or just
develop in its we're sort of developing
it because we're we just moved Studios
and we're gonna have to get that set up
and once that set up and things are
running smoothly there mm-hmm I'm gonna
try to do some of that stuff but it's
very expensive and the thing about that
is it's really hard to you know I might
even I don't know it would be nice if
somebody like Netflix wanted it but I
don't know well yeah so I was wondering
how how do you finance something like
that the way that I've always done it is
just on some ships and CPM and I try to
make do with what I have and I have a
budget for like every episode do you
secure sponsors ahead of time yeah
though that well I'll get it ahead of
time maybe like two months and then I'll
say what's my deadline they're gonna be
my deadline and I delivered to them
interesting on the deadline school they
you have that relationship with them
yeah well it's different every time
that's the thing because it's a
multitude of sponsors you can pitch an
idea to say whoever and be like hey I'm
working on this travel show are you guys
up for sponsoring two or three episodes
or whatever yeah yeah we could that that
is one method III generally
because I have like it's like your show
like cuz you know that there's like a
show like an h3 h3 show that you do yeah
periodically right I don't really need
to tell people what it is they already
know they wanted on a Kijana episode
yeah but like yeah that's a whole
different thing yeah you could if you
wanted to like go like I never like I
never talked about this gonna stuff you
could like go out to a sponsor and ask
them if they wanted to sponsor it that
that's one method of doing it I'm sure
you guys do that kind of stuff to you
yeah yeah general I mean generally the
way it works for us is like someone's
like hey I wanna sponsor a video that's
basically how I did where they come
through agency and then that's how we
started this podcast yeah really we yeah
we had sponsors from the beginning
oh yeah the podcast actually wasn't and
we knew we needed a budget to do this
and we were this was the one except yeah
I feel like the thing is when you're
uncertain it's harder to you have to be
like okay we've planning out like a
twelve part series and do you want to
sponsor that whereas we can just to take
it as it comes approach also works cuz
it's like if we get a certain sponsor
and it might fit on that video it's like
okay this is our chance we know we're
gonna get that budget let's go make it
I'm a little bit more on the run-and-gun
side because YouTube's a bit like that
but yeah I do sometimes wish that I had
a more structured thing but that's kind
of what makes YouTube fun you just kind
of go with it if there's no I liked it
on you you know what I do think about
because if you have like a television
show or something like that it has to be
like twenty one minutes long you know
right but we can make it as long or one
I think that's really cool yeah because
it doesn't need to be any longer or any
shorter than it needs to be sure
sometimes we don't appreciate yeah the
things that we have on you I think about
that like imagine how maddening you have
your video has to be twenty three
minutes long yeah like what no I think
about that all the time to put in crap
or yeah take something you like to wait
to get notes from the network yeah you
thought that's the biggest thing and
then they might want to take out your
favorite part right and then that's I
have to tell you like one of the biggest
reasons that I haven't like moved on to
something like that is just because I
really like not having anyone tell me
what to make I just really like it it's
it's not like to me it's the best thing
but yeah you obviously always have that
thing it's like one for the money one
for the show sometimes you you've got to
stick to a format or you won't be able
to keep it going nothing you don't like
format but sometimes obviously everyone
has a creative aspirations or like if I
just somebody just handed me this fat
sack of money Oh what I could make yeah
and I do think that sometimes because
I'm watching if you Jerry Seinfeld's
fine exactly but ya know but the thing
is right yeah I don't mean to I one of
the reasons I don't like talking about
this is because it sounds like I'm not
enjoying what I'm making now that's not
the case it's just that it won't be cool
to make other stuff yeah I had the
chance there's no need to hide like the
business aspect of what we do it is a
business yeah it's tough it is a
business because you wouldn't be able to
make these good people always say John
you know your new stuffs to over produce
and it's like yeah okay I'm gonna tell
you how much you're gonna enjoy it if I
go back to filming it on my handy cam
well I'll get anymore
I think I disagree in a way and that
there's a difference between like home
charm of like shooting a new Lehrer but
you do a lot of high budget stuff you
have like special effects you have props
you go to plate you go locations you
have really good employee like that that
to me is money well spent Sergio Sergio
Andrew Mike yeah you know who you are I
love you no no yeah Melanie I've gotta
go through mom now somebody's gonna get
offended I love the people I work I know
them um but I find charm and like your
old video shot in your apartment but
then but at any rate there's a lot
surrounding it that cause I tell you
wanna you've all my right here's the
here's the yes you're right but it that
that too but also the thing about charm
is the reason it's charming is because
it's not replicatable like okay
sometimes everything are pushing
yourself to a new limit is the charm cuz
a lot of times I want to challenge
myself because I like getting like
legitimate reactions out of myself that
I didn't expect I find that's like one
way to get charm in like comedy and if
you do the same it's almost like telling
the same jokes million times start to
lose the keep challenging you're wasting
make a new joke or tell it in a
different way or right that's just yeah
I that's cool that makes a lot of sense
to me it's not like if you went back
into your house and shot it the old way
it would be the same yeah I'm not that
person
yeah you're not yeah we definitely get
the same but you know what it's like I
there's something um people it's a
nostalgia thing really it's like there's
something when when you see something
like new and fresh you know it's it's
just this good way more yeah well people
are remembering the first time they saw
you and it's like more yeah like oh my
god this is amazing - just something
personal that was happening in your life
at that time when you were watching it I
was just gonna say there reminds you
that feeling it's gonna related to the
video yeah a lot of times actually cause
like I'm sure I don't know if you've
heard of this but I've done this where
I'm like this new thing sucks and the
old thing is better I gonna play the
whole thing and I'm like yeah you know
it's funny it's like that but but some
some things stand the test of time and
you go back and watch them and find out
even better than you thought
all right like the lord of rings movies
I know I didn't think I can like them
anymore went back and watch them
recently I was like they're really good
like I don't know the case of well
anyway
are you done making video game content
oh you know this is probably a great
platform to not necessarily no not
really I just it's just if it catches my
fancy I will do it and that's pretty
much just the way that my approach to
things is now I'm not I know people look
at me like a like a gamer but I've never
really I've always really I've preferred
the comedy side of it you know like if
it's funny that I'll do it right I don't
really care what it is that's funny I
mean when I found your channel
I'm not gay I mean I'm I've never
watched gaming content on YouTube but
somehow I watched your videos about
video games and they were entertaining
to me remember that tweet the first
tweet combo we had I don't know what did
he mean it at me like dude love your
content yeah and I was like I screwed up
I actually mistook you for another
person yeah
and I was like wait who's this I thought
this was a different youtuber and then I
saw your video that's been seeing and I
was like this is some funny crap dudes
and then I found your reaction videos
dude you like pioneer then that was good
but I remember once back then they go is
the gamergate SUV SUV we're driving yeah
the lawn order everyone Lu yes that was
like oh yeah yeah anyway he leveled up
they level that B we'll wait Toby cousin
back then I just feel like everything
was so fresh yeah everything was so
fertile oh yeah that was like the dawn
of the road am emoney I hate to keep
using anything no that was the dawn of
it cuz yeah before there was there was
no like organized way to roast all this
so I never even watched YouTube before
we started making those videos yeah once
we started we to find out like pranks
guys that was the meaning we found
pranks I gotta say cuz you've been
saying so much nice stuff I gotta return
it because I uh you guys like just like
pioneered that whole thing that holds
your honor I'm so know cuz like thanks
like there's no it's funny because I
remember thinking that I wanted to do
stuff like that's I hadn't had the exact
any of what it is but you know like how
do I get this same length formula with
you know what I do is I did videos in
movies and then you guys because there's
something funny about when you're taking
like some honey from the from the
current real world and just taking them
to task because they did I think back
then thank you like real jealous like
happy jealous like I'd be like Taylor
making such good kind of that's nice
that's how we felt when we found out in
my really yeah I never forget when Ethan
told me you got to see this guy that I
found on YouTube like I'll never forget
so unattainable quality I know Chen and
I was like oh my god like how do I make
my videos like that you know it's crazy
well it was I felt the same way about
you thanks man that's really [ __ ]
cool to hear yeah it's like you
motivates I was totally man 100% and
well first I'll say my back off yeah you
get your dick out [ __ ] louis c.k
jerk-off fun know if you're asking yeah
i heard yes I heard yes yeah anyone
anyway about that specific video the
gamergate one is that i remember that
you tweeted it out for us
ones I did yeah I think it was the you
tweeted it out and yeah it made like
this huge impact where a lot of rebels
found our Channel who didn't know about
just that was sweet it was just one
tweet I remember I remember there was a
time when it was just like fire all of a
sudden and then like ah the last year
especially you know it's like just
looking at your numbers and I'm like hmm
let's see what's happened here like it's
just crazy cereal it's it's surreal I'm
sure you know what I mean like just like
two years ago you know we were real that
year was magical for us because we had
nothing to lose yeah
nobody [ __ ] knew or cared about
anything we did or said I could [ __ ]
talk on anybody in the world and they
probably wouldn't watch it it probably
wouldn't care just a no consequence half
of our there's no consequence half of
the videos I did shirtless just because
I thought it was I know this last year
has been really rough creatively he has
it been now so I'm curious no I'm just
I'm still exploring the feelings yeah
dude you know especially because sorry
what just say we've it's I don't know
it's kind of complicated we're trying to
understand ourselves what happened in
the past year yeah I guess dealing with
a lot of negativity that that's the
worst part and it's funny because when
you guys started growing I was like I
see because I've been through that not
especially you guys are really exploding
things but like I know that negativity
part comes and it really sucks it's hard
to deal with and then you start to not
know what's real yeah like there could
be like 98 percent positivity but you
really notice that 2 percent negativity
it's just like coming to terms with like
the fact that I am realizing that I've
changed for the worse
almost I saw that tweet I know you're
talking about no we have a name yeah
yeah I mean except we haven't hung out a
lot but and I don't know we've been very
private to and very hold up the past
year I have been the same way though
it's funny because the it does your
you're up here on this
platform with all these people and
sometimes it just as too much and you
kind of well I did out I didn't really
know how to even materialize the
feelings because I just felt negative
all the time I know what you're talking
like aunt remember the last time I shot
a video and I was like happy and it was
a fun positive experience oh man I went
through that phase you know what you do
break through it eventually when you
just realize well I'm gonna put it out
there they like it they like it if they
don't ah c'est la vie I just like yeah I
don't I have a lot like that I'm
confronting right now about it but well
I just feel like I've been turned into a
shittier person oh it's okay I mean not
to you but I don't know who's been on
the end of this I mean I didn't like
rape or kill anyone I'm not sure it's
like I was thinking to myself in the old
today I was like well the good news is I
didn't rape kill or molest any I'm just
an [ __ ] well you know what dude I
well I mean I can't pretend there's no
there's no specific instance I'm just
thinking about I know what you're
talking about
how I interact we've both been feeling
it it's I know what you're talking about
I think at least I mean I don't know
exactly what you're talking about
but I know that that feeling of
negativity that comes with too much
overstimulation
too many people wanting to yeah get
something from you or I don't know
exactly what it is that you're talking
about but I know say I'm trying really
have it in words yes innit cynical is a
good word how you became very cynical
very distrustful very cynical is a very
good way to put it very looking at
people with the word like I see the
worst in people right away and then like
I give that out to the world and I and I
have this feeling like that people don't
like me as well
oh well that's it's probably in your
head man I think secluding ourselves too
much yeah my it's just deep yeah
I know exactly we're talking about I
don't think it's hard to talk about
stuff yeah it's hard yeah it's a very
it's a very personal experience for
ourselves and you really don't have any
I'm just I'm thinking our audience
probably won't you know the audience
doesn't think about this they just see
the phone totally and it's and it's
frustrating anyway it's a conversation
for though time but ya know I don't want
to get I don't want to probe to D just
thinking about it it's fine I
on top I guarantee I want to talk about
it but I need to think about it a lot
yeah I think it's because I I know that
people are wondering about it because
that tweet was dramatic I was really
curious in fact we didn't even talk
about yeah I was wondering I I'm sure
it's not as bad as for thinking it's any
rate it's whatever it's just more in a
personal yeah it's a personal it sure I
don't wanna
yeah no it's not I'm talking about a
voluntarily you're just whatever it's
like let me let me just say what is it
with the Dutch no assisted suicide
during the material out okay
you don't need to save this podcast
because I'm a suicidal new suicide
machine with detachable coffin I don't
wait what new suicide machine with
detachable coffin lets you kill yourself
anytime anywhere is that a parody no
it's [ __ ] real and I tell you what
can you pull that up please Dan Aryan I
have actually some there's something
about like the the Nordic pipes and
assisted suicide because you can go
there to get euthanized there like you
know life I'm kind of dumb
I just wanna someone to help me exit it
I have a friend who I have actually a
couple of easily I have a friend whose
grandmother a very dear friend of mine
just she was like the hundredth person
in the whole country to elect to take
her own life
legally it was a really interesting
thing like I I didn't know that was the
thing here in the United States I
thought it was illegal but it was here
yeah the United States we're getting it
too and so she talked to she had talked
to a psychologist she had to get go to a
doctor and get cleared and the state is
like okay you have permission to end
your life now legally has it been
slowing down yeah it has been
I've seen a couple things like that but
I didn't know we could do it here I
thought it was a big no-no here yeah I
think it's I think it's beautiful like
she she was terminally ill if you and
she was suffering so like for her it was
like a way to go with dignity right
that's what they call it like going with
and I think it's a great thing but it's
just like so weird to wrap your head
around that yes yes I like that's too
much isn't it it's fun it's light enough
just kill yourself instantly basket was
I'm sitting here pouring out my heart
what do you expect me to step into one
of those John you gonna fight I know it
I know it's my Christmas gift you know
it's funny
okay on the way here I have to qualify
this on the way here I wrote a list of
like funny stuff like I even wrote I'll
tell you when I wrote it the earpods
we just do haven't got past the stigma
of the Bluetooth headset cuz you look
like a real douchebag walking around
hell I put him in the wrong way but when
you feel so good yeah you don't care to
have those cool headphones like the Bose
right out there actually funny okay so
what should you prefer now these really
but these one I don't think you can sync
these up to other stuff maybe you can
but of course you can't
Apple let me let me don't have you you
might be able to but here this little
tic tac box is it ticked X no it's $200
piece of plastic I'll tell you what you
put him on you take it out and put them
on in your ears ago so you can't hear it
because mmm and then you're connected I
listen to safety dance I have to oh I
have to tell a story about this okay
the ever gone and played a song on
Spotify and then the the playlist will
like you play like one song like some
Billy Joel song and then it like
automatically goes to the next songs on
the search right I got into some you can
get into some crazy stupid down the
rabbit hole I went on safety dance at
like you know that song yes and I'm
having a good time like like you know
getting some material for the show and
then it goes to the next song which is
safety dance with like the crazy frog
was like ring ding ding ding ding
all of a sudden who let the Frog you
know
dance to who let the frog out they say
three spots bro you went straight down
the meme oh man
can I use it I play like a song uh
actually yeah you guys should go check
out who let the frog out or the crazy
frog version of I wanna go I can go back
in time just a little bit because I am
quite interested about this oh yeah I
want to swing it to me Fallon hair
ruffle that you [ __ ] shook the world
this is the new machine no suicide
machine with detachable coffin let you
kill yourself Anytime Anywhere it's on
Oprah's olace gotta see this year this
Christmas everyone's going crazy about
this new suicide machine I like how the
title is written like a commercial exact
you can do it anytime anywhere it's like
it's it's a millennial suicide box bro
what's with the detachable coffin like
what are you just like it's like a like
a like did you conveyor belt it if you
do it on the side of a ship you can get
ditched like an old Navy sailor listen
to this [ __ ] are you sure this isn't
parody Australia's best known euthanasia
activist it's not a best no there are
actually some lesser-known euthanasia
doctors Scylla is back in the news why
is it so silly designed to it looks too
cool for what you're doing there I know
you get back yourselves with dignity be
killed
step into the future one of those
infomercials three easy steps
sit gas and it's yeah it's basically a
tape commercial tape off your life to
kill myself I saw it myself in half got
him maybe I'll make you not wanna come
in suicide cuz it's like look we have
cool stuff here maybe you want to change
your mind this is [ __ ] weird it looks
like a spaceship like you I guess you
are going on the final journey right I
would love first I would love for that
thing to just rocket you
well you stay if they got me to say if
it said you can now be buried in orbit
and you will go for as long as the as
the earth he's there I would do it
there'd be too much paid space junk of
[ __ ] corpses floating around the
earth do you know I actually saw a space
junk map in terms of price limit it's a
lot of space yeah and sometimes it just
falls to earth yes which you know like
my job though right no no like makes it
like I just saw a thing on it like these
big guests like propane tank type things
just like no no burning up you might
burn up that's nice I like other space
junk that's just what I need
like I'm not neurotic enough just
propane tanks blowing through space now
you get killed by a skeleton hurtling
towards Earth no one would be the most
disappointing thing about this machine
you just can't open it from the inside
you just trapped like you got a lemon
and then turn on I'm not even dead I'm
alive common out of 10 the fact that I'm
leaving this review is speaks alright
let's find the dumplings pretty funny
yeah I don't know you're like let me see
if I got any more because I know we're
probably Jimmy alright let's see this
some fun Trump during the taping of The
Tonight Show today did I miss your hair
this is during the campaign yeah the
campaign the answer is yes
[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna have a guy on your show why
would you what was the Matis ISM bet
what the cause isn't what that was that
a humanized Trump look at what was their
actual apology yeah I look at it it's
hilarious I don't know if he said it
himself but like Jimmy Fallon apology
Trump afford Trump hair
well you just Trump apology or probably
Donald Trump interviews himself in
mirror somehow I don't think it'll be
like was it a statement or video I don't
know just look it up on Google like
Jimmy Fallon Trump hair apology
okay yeah there you go see is sorry not
sorry
oh that's out I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
not sorry I'm not watching Jimmy Fallon
anymore since he ruffled some air I
swear he apologized for this I could
grow I think he apologized for it I was
trying to have fun that's the horrible I
can't [ __ ] say man then of course -
show us - yeah yada yada look I thought
we were just going out there for some
fun one thing led to another was
ruffling some hair yeah it's a gateway
humor
all right well I guess let's see here a
couple more things making her way
through here one thing I did want to ask
you that a lot of people this was the
number one question on our subreddit so
I feel obligated to ask you I'm not
gonna pressure you to say whatever you
want about it but a lot of people even
to this day which I know is insane
people are weird about this you know
what's coming
the game people want to know what's the
real story but how much game drum [ __ ]
you want to trouble you want to get me
I'm just I'm just asking the questions
people want it was nothing really
honestly just some creative differences
that's it the end please stop asking me
okay
I mean there's like people are like
there's like a subreddit called it was
it grumps Perry's grumped grumpily
yeah yeah well I so Glade had a lot of
success I'm really happy for them
there's no bad blood it's fine is this
really your number one on our summer
look I I don't want to just here's the
thing if I sit here and
go can't answer that can't answer that
looks worse there's nothing it's no big
deal it was like five years ago you know
we we were just on different creative
pets and then that's it that's a very
fair and respectable answer thank you
for your frankness yeah I got a joke
when I was actually pretty proud of okay
whose show is this piece they say rome
fell we always talk about the fall of
Rome how do you think that makes it I
think you can get a flight there from
JFK the Roman guy you living in Rome
comes outside said hey in fall it's
right here it's still here what do you
mean it's standing right now mr. saying
that to people who say funny stuff you
know what stick to comedy
you're a huge fan of Star Wars Oh
merchandise it too so that I never see
anything but Star Wars in all of my
peripheral vision right yeah but I'd
love Star Wars my favorite things just
in case you forget about it yeah just in
case you didn't remember the most have
you been following the he a debacle with
the new game oh yeah I some I have to
say I would I just got an Xbox one is
pretty damn cool system I'm working and
everything and I saw like I don't you
know what I don't think it was
battlefront but it was like World War
Call of Duty World War two and they were
selling it for like it was like it was
like a hundred and ten dollars slash
only 89 and I'm like since when yeah
Battlefront that's the new Star Wars
gaming it was like 80 bucks
oh no the Xbox I was like when did this
happen yeah I - hiking yeah I thought
600 was like them I guess it was the
collector's edition but I do remember
when we were kids games used to cost 40
bucks
hmm you remember that um PlayStation
well also bus rides in Israel used to
cost like nothing I everything I just
change that I refuse to believe it that
was the end of an era
it went from 40 to 60 it's been 60 for a
long feeling like did you know what I
have been feeling they're trying to edge
it up but they're not really get being
successful because of like steam seems
like you're gonna have for $5.00 yeah
right the thing is the thing is with the
battlefront thing what people were
pissed about if I understand correctly
was the fact that you could buy was just
payable in Darth Vader for like forty
$80 it was a little big it was just it
was a total pay to win skin like gone in
the Sun wild and I gotta say some cuz
I'm a big you know this I was just by
the way I'm back in the counter-strike
and I haven't played since my name on
Steam is still there and I've been
racking up kills on Saint John the
Divine the skin John I know it's a great
skin and it's funny by the way just an
anecdote we used to play so much and
then it was the holidays and we bought
each other like $300 skins and then we
never played but we used to call John
Saint John the Divine anyway you know
everything no it's what I was saying was
microtransactions III like them I really
don't mind them because like certain
games get supported forever by
microtransactions like in like skins in
in counter-strike it's so awesome ro no
I don't think anyone has problems with
skins because that's cosmetics yeah cut
if it's just cosmetic god bless make
money and make cool stuff that I can
choose to buy yeah but the moment that
it affects the game yeah the balance of
the game you [ __ ] up I'm gonna be
honest with you I just the only have to
say is if if they're so stupid to do
something that's stupid in a game that
big you had it coming
why would you put pay2win in a Star Wars
they're just brazen like they're they're
they're running that model to the
farthest limit yeah of the universe I
don't have anything look
morally against it but it's like come on
Yin it's they really I mean I don't even
feel like they provide the entertainment
per dollar like other games like csgo is
like 15 bucks best game ever they
updated all the time like why you got a
charge I understand it's a big company
they need to make their investment back
they put hundreds of millions dollars in
these games I understand but they do
seem to just really put some insane
prices alright I they're testing a limit
of like playability they're they're just
trying to find the sweet spot of
playability first how much money can we
actually milk this game for yeah and
that mean you know that's what they do
but it's [ __ ] annoying because it
would be otherwise fun game but nobody
wants to grind for 80 hours just to play
Darth Vader yeah when they're 80 paid
$80 for the game well yeah I mean the
funny thing is this I know this was like
a big topic it doesn't really buy for
some reason this stuff's never riled me
I'm like that's a bad business model it
will fail naturally does does it not I
feel like this is the first time because
I have this article here that says their
stock actually dropped 8.5% they lost
3.1 billion dollar shareholder value
since the release of battlefront it's a
bad bit but that's the first time I've
actually seen a company get [ __ ] by it
but then on the other hand if you pull
out even further like in the past year
their stock is up like a ungodly amount
in the feel way up I mean it's a EA is
just one of those big faceless
corporations and they just make you know
God knows that how in touch they are
maybe they think that's a good idea
I don't know they've got algorithms and
guys with charts and by the way I want
to say like I'm talking specifically
about competitive games like mobile
games especially like it's fine to buy
[ __ ] if it you have to monetize it I'm
not saying like across the board but
when you have like a competitive game
when people with more I guess that's the
moral quandary it's like you have a
competition and people with more income
get an edge it's kind of lame to give
them that it ruins it does ruin the
integrity of the game yeah it does ya
know do you actually get like an edge by
being Darth Vader or Luke they I yeah I
think there's also Bible items that that
make you better at your character
oh I played the first one and I just
remember that you would get them like as
an item like you'd like run up to it and
you would get I think they changed that
oh I don't know I haven't played this
game yeah I really can't comment on it
yeah well this [ __ ] interesting I've
got a ton of videos to watch but we've
covered logging around there pretty long
going right oh we've covered a lot of
ground my friends never talked about Jim
Carrey oh well you want to talk about it
it's great I loved it yeah I loved it
too
we're talking about the Netflix let's
say what we're talking about
okay the documentary on Netflix about
Jim Carrey's role as Andy Kaufman ah you
remember what it's called man on the
moon no no the documentary oh it's
called like as you like Andy yeah Jim
and Andy yeah yeah and so as he's
talking about how playing this role as
as him changed like changed him yeah and
I don't know it's [ __ ] it definitely
got me thinking because I he's just
talking about how he like the underlying
messages like he got everything he
wanted
and he was still unhappy yeah definitely
I mean I it's a time old tale isn't it
but I tell you yes coming from Jim I
guess it's especially Jim Carrey like
the funniest man one of those quotes
that got me so hard he was like I played
the guy who had no worries so then other
people wouldn't have to be worried or
say yeah and I was like that's throw a
little convenient but I tell you he's
just I don't know it just met
I think it's funny cuz half the stuff he
was saying I was like right on that
makes sense the other half I was like
you're insane yeah you didn't break
character for like see I was insane yeah
there was definitely like and you can
see that before our new are like kind of
cringing I know it's funny because it's
like it's Jim Carrey you're supposed to
be like wow what a method actor it's
like Jim you don't gotta be in character
it was really interesting though yeah
really interesting I I think it's like I
think he really did Channel and to him
Andy Kaufman because the whole thing was
about how he never knew he was you never
know when to stop
yeah he would take the character so far
that you never knew what was real and
what was what was fake and the fact that
they recorded it makes it yeah like
another face on its own the fact that he
was having a documentary and crew with
him the whole thing was like a
performance yeah yeah
I mean he was very aware of that I think
probably less than he leads on in the
documentary have you seen man on the
moon
I actually I have I've seen it yeah I
mean apparently it's quite good yeah I
can't uh yeah I read the article all
right yeah all right all right well I
mean I'm a couple slices tomorrow comes
to you had a few too many we would go to
it was in the freezing cold
you know it wasn't we see that we had
some great night some great what one you
know what if I ever come back on this
I'll just compile all that crazy [ __ ]
yeah and bring it so you so the people
can see that a year be special little
cassette yeah all right let's go get
drunk I need some pizza guys thank you
John thank you so much for coming thank
you having me thanks for
don't appreciate and I love I love you
saying right back at you I think that I
think very highly I think you're a great
guy and you're too not the way you do
and right back at you
thanks man guys thank you everyone for
tuning in spending your day with us we
love you we appreciate you for coming by
next week is what I say Philip DeFranco
wild sprinkle on Friday gonna post the
thread to post your questions for the
guy looking forward to see you guys then
thank you for tuning in and watching
yeah thanks for watching see you guys
next time
Tata